[demonic Jack Black noises+he needs a shave)
Felix: He's crazy(search up Pipy Squad)
Felix: BACK OFF!
Jack: What is this?
BACK OFF!
HEY
HE'S THROWING EGGS
I'M NOT THROWING ANYTHING
I know exactly what you mean but this time we're just gonna have to wing it
Jablinski are you connected to the server?
Where are you?(stalker)
No, in minecraft *Felix laughs*
"Felix chuckling"
yes?
Good to meet you too man
Here in minecraft
It's been a long time coming
Yeah
I'm old school gamer
*felix snickers*
AHA I saw.. I saw that yeah, that was great
yep
"Felix laughs"
HEY don't call it dumb
[slightly exhales out of nose]
Jack: IT'S A MASTERPIECE
it's uh
It's a little like.. (stammers)
like
it's like
It was like Mozart of videogames
It created a world
and it becomes the biggest game in the world.
A game within in a game with a world within a world
Felix: The only world you need -
Jack: here's a powerful shakespearean lesson in
in the Notch story
yeah
Uhhh I need to crack it
and I was thinking alot about it
and uhm
you know this producer who does all of the MCU, The Marvel Comics (Cinematic) Universe
His name is uh, Kevin Feige
Felix: Is that his real name?
Jack: And look at what he's done over the last 10 years
Felix: Yeah
Where he just, like, puppet-mastered all of these stories, all of these movies
like, 25 movies
Half of them, billion-dollar franchises
Felix: Oh, really? Subscribe to BergBayColony
Jack: All leading towards this one, mega thing with uh,
Felix: With Minecraft
Jack: No, it's a separate thing
*Felix chuckles*
Jack: With "End(s)game"
Felix: Oh, I see
Jack: It's a master stroke of cinema (french word)
this guy
i think has proven that he's the only guy to produce
Notch: The Movie
so i just decided right now, Kevin Feige you're hired
*Felix laughs*
Felix: alright we're just gonna go and go pick uhh... some flowers
because I need... for your shield
And then we should be all set
Jack: Look out! Zombie
Felix: Thanks brah
Jack: No problem I got you bro
Heyyyyy you got an achievement! Nice
Jack: yeah
jack: Umm.. I dont see any chickens but if there is any chickens here dude
we'd be
we'd be feasting
Felix : we'll find someth...
Jack: OHTHERESTHEMEATBALL!!
Felix: theres the meat ball!
hey
lemme show you the meat ball jack
Jack: dude i could see that meatball literally from a mile away
Felix: that's because it's so beautiful and so big
Jack: I don't know if I believe that you made that meatball entirely
on your own
Felix: NO! (random word) JACK
Jack: I feel like maybe you left some of that work
Felix: JACK! (pause) NUH-*wheezes*
Jack: to your minions
Felix: *wheezing laugh*
*jack laughs, felix still laughing*
Jack: That's a lot of work there
Felix: Listen,
I play a lot of mineCRA-HA-FT *both laugh*
so uhh, I appreciate that you're calling me out here
live, so i could defend myself
YES I BUILT IT MYSELF! Thank you very much
and Jack, even though you just insulted my meatball
I'm gonna give you this honorary swedish shield
*blop*Jack: UGGHH, alright
thank you
Felix: You're wel-
Jack: I know just what to do-
There it is
BOOM
Felix: Yeeahh! Alright
"Felix copying Matthew McConaughey" Alright alright alright
I wish you had uh,
*chuckles*
different skin but
this is dope
Jack: if uhh,
if this wasn't live, there would definitely be a Matthew McCounaghey meme
right then when you said that
*Felix impersonates Matthew McCounaghey again"
*Jack impersonates Matthew McCounaghey"
Felix: Alright, lets check out the meatball
Jack: wait, I can't open this door
Felix: uh you gotta hit the button
Jack: *high pitch voice* wait, i thought i hit the button
Felix: right click it
Jack: OH THAT BUTTON
Felix: This button
It's hidden
Jack: It's a hidden button
Ohhh, that's
yeah of course duh
Felix: You go ahead Jablinski
Jack: Why thank you
Felix: I'll hold the door open for you
Okay, and then stand-
Oh wait i gotta reset it first
and then stand on the thing
and then you gotta stand still
One sec okay?
Jack: kay
Felix: I don't know if this will work in multiplayer to be honest
*piston noises*
OH NO!!
"both laughs"
Felix: NAHAAW!
Jack: What just happened?
Felix: get ou--don't know *laughing*
Jack: I don't think I'm supposed to be in here
Felix: *laughing noise*
yeahyeahyeah
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine
Felix: So, tell me honestly
Is this the finest meatball you've ever seen?
Jack: Well, I mean
Dude
Of course it is
That's the- Felix: Thank you, thank you
Jack: GOOD LOR- It's like the Death Star of meatballs
*Felix laughs*
Felix: I like to see it as that
Jack: That meatball
could destroy a planet
Felix: OH, I have an idea! Follow me
Okay, so this is the famous IKEA tower
Jack: OOHHH!
Felix: It's beautiful this time o' year
Jack: You know I recently built an IKEA bed for my son
Felix: *chuckles* Really?
Jack: And and I did almost all by myself
Felix: *slight laughter in voice* Almost all by yourself?
Jack: I was pretty proud of it
My wife had to come in on uhh
Step 27
Felix: Aww, What happened on step 27?
Jack: Just some screwing (Haha, get it?)
Could we go up there?
Felix: oh yeah, yehyeh follow me
Jack: But uhh
I also found it oddly satisfying
It was hard work but
at the end of the day it was kinda like LEGOS
Felix: yeah
Jack: You know what I mean?
Where you just follow the directions
Felix: yeah
Felix: I really like building IKEA stuff
Jack: Yeah! If you follow it really strictly-
Felix: Unless step 27
Jack: -It works
I did have to call an IKEA expert at one point
at step 29
but they
they knew what they we're-
they we're right there with me
Felix: Did they have a swedish accent?
Jack: No, that was-
Felix: WHAT!?
-just a dude
That was a dude from Fresno
I was talking to
On the hotline
Felix: Fake IKEA
Okay
Here we are
Almost at the top
Don't push me alright?
Jack: Hey! Is Swedish Accent-
(stammers) Now, forgive my, my ignorance
Cause I don- I haven't studied wtih the Swedish accent yet
*in swedish accent* Is it kinda of a "flurton, hurton, durton" ? ( I don't really know what he said)
*Felix laughs*
Felix: See, this is why, no, this why
Jack: *continues making swedish noises*
you're perfect for the Notch role
*Jack laughs*
That was absolutely perfect
Felix: All the way to the top
Okay careful, okay careful care-
Jack: OH GOSH
Felix: *laughing* careful up here
Jack: *inaudible sound* - get to the top
Felix: Okay Jack
If you look down-
Don't be scared
Jack: HHNNGH
*Felix laughs*
Jack: Yeah?
Felix: You're fine
Uhh
*giggling*
Jab- Jablinski, there's something
I haven't
told you
Jack: *confused* what, what?
Felix: *soft giggle*
Uhhm soo
My fiance's very first crush
*doubled voice* was you
Jack: NO WAY!
*faint music playing on the background*
Felix: And I thi- Jack: When she was what?
Felix: When she was 14
Felix: And I thin- Jack: OH MY GOD
Felix: I think that means I have to kill you in minecraft
*minecraft hit sound effect*
Jack: NOOOOOO-
O-HAHAHAAAARGH
Felix: I'M SORRY!